[Musique]
6 c'est le nombre de fresques peintes à
château en 2021 parmi elles 2 met à
l'honneur la ville des impressionnistes
au golden street art le concours lancé
par trompe-l'oeil point info récompense
la plus belle fresque réalisée en france
durant l'année écoulée
présélectionné parmi quarante oeuvres de
france elles se sont hissées parmi les
dix finalistes des fresques d'artistes
internationaux comme diversité de vigny
graffiti artiste française toulousaine
qui est jeune qui est de 1982 dont
vraiment et qui a une audience on va
dire internationale puisque ces fresques
sont dans le monde entier et voilà avec
une thématique est bien particulière
c'est ce visage que de la jeune fille
quiconque est récurrent sur toutes ces
oeuvres deuxième oeuvre à intégrer le
top 10 celle de carlos alberto artistes
mexicains une fresque en 3d végétales et
animales hier sur le thème du
développement durable l habiller le mur
du collège auguste renoir il a pris en
fait un petit peu les oiseaux qui assure
sur chatouille martin-pêcheur d'aider
des agneaux quoi retrouver le résultat
plutôt superbe ici à chatou chacun à sa
favorite celle qui est là-bas ou sinon
la petite fresque si oui ça aussi c'est
très beau il en fait cet été oui le
l'oiseau juste devant
juste devant le collège oui c'est très
beau celle des sabines est qui et sur
les bâtiments orange lab h3c la marianne
si je me trompe pas où c'est une dame en
tout cas qui a dessiné dessus je sais
plus trop mais c'est ça la plus jolie je
trouve ma préférée c'est la jeune fille
qui a dessiné or c'est une artiste une
petite artiste qui a dessiné avec des
mots dans les cheveux elle a des cheveux
crépus et des bouclettes vous pouvez
voter pour votre presque préféré sur le
site trompe-l'oeil clôture des votes le
samedi 19 février à 20 heures
[Musique]